hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website com2 they're gonna be
going over a game from 1912 thought to
be one of the best in games in chess
some have considered at the gold coins
game after the last move in this game it
was said that the spectators threw gold
coins on the board we're not really sure
if that was just because it was an
amazing move at the end or if they were
paying their bets all that to say is
it's an exciting match especially to the
very end the opponents today what's
gonna be played by Stephane Levinsky
he's a Russian chess master used to be a
national chess champion which says a lot
in Russia and also he introduced the
Queen's Bishop attack any time you have
your an attack you're gonna be a pretty
strong player
he's although best known for this
particular match his opponent playing
the black pieces is Frank Marshall u.s.
legend earlier in the 20th century 27
straight years being the US chess
champion definitely a strong player so
we're go ahead and get into it
Levinsky starts out with pawn to d4 we
see pawn e6 pawn e4 and then pawn to d5
getting into the French defense play
continues with Knight to c3 and then
pawn to c5 interesting third move from
Frank Marshall you're usually going to
see pawn capture here on e4 Bishop
coming down pending the night here on b4
even the knight coming here to c6 pretty
common but pawn to c5 not the most
common from here Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and then pawn taking here on d5
recapture here and then Bishop here to e
2 and E twos not the most aggressive
move usually you can bring your Bishop
out here to b5 a really aggressive
pinning down this Knight right here
this Knight is protecting and attacking
this square here on d4 very essential
square that he may decide to go into
with this pawn here on d4 but Bishop to
e2 is completely fun getting ready to
castle on the kingside Med over here to
f6 just controlling the center of the
board
so castle a bishop here to e7 and then
Bishop over here to G's 5 so doing a
good job of getting his dark squared
Bishop involved into the game all he
needs to do now is get his queen
involved to the game Queen here to d2
makes a lot of sense connect his rooks
he's completed his development on the
other side the board Frank Marshall has
a little bit more to do castle on the
Kings side
his LightSquared bishop involvement to
the game and then get his queen involved
we do see the king castle first and then
pawn taking here on c5 bishop here to e6
and white black has a few options here
he could take it with his bishop here on
c5 this is probably what I would do
myself but Bishop here to east six is
fine this pond it's not really gonna be
protected the Queen's not gonna come
here to d4 just be captured the pawns
not gonna come here to b4 it's just
gonna be captured by the knight both of
these cases so I can kind of have an
in-between move the bishop here to e6 he
knows he has to do that to complete this
development so this just allows him to
take that pawn a little bit later in the
game night here to d4 and then the
bishop here does c5 as we talked about
now the Knights gonna take here on e6
and this is kind of an interesting spot
for white here as far as what he really
wants to do on board I don't really like
taking with my nights here on e6 you you
do sometimes want to get your opponent's
bishops off the board giving them double
bishop pair it's pretty dangerous but as
Frank Marshall captures back here Frank
Karsch all of a sudden has two pawns in
the state of the board a White has no
central pawns so that's definitely gonna
be a bad thing and it's not always bad
to give up your F pawn right here for
black especially after you castled you
just now have a semi-open pile for your
rook to kind of dominate this side of
the board so this is just gonna add more
pressure especially with his bishop here
on c5 putting a lot of pressure here on
f2 as soon as this knight moves later
into the game which you want to announce
pin down but this would kind of open up
the door for an attack right here so
oh no I kind of get why Stefan wouldn't
want to play this Knight to e6 but right
now this light square bishop is not
doing anything it's protecting this pawn
here on d5 so I think there's just some
other moves even Bishop here to e3 you
know this way after the knight takes
here on e6 if there's a recapture all of
a sudden this bishops going to fall so
black has to take that into
consideration as he is recapturing so
although we see Knight to e6 I'm not
thrilled with it but the pawn recaptures
and then Bishop here to g4
attacking this backward pawn right here
on e6 which I do like but all of a
sudden the Queen too
six protecting this pawn on e6 and we
see Frank Marshall with a huge huge
buildup and they're suing the board he's
definitely winning just by the mere fact
that he's controlling the center usually
if you control the turn the board in
chess
you're doing really really well on board
from here we do see the bishop come back
here to h3 and there's just not a ton of
great moves that white has in this
particular case but bringing that bishop
back here to h3 is completely fine ruk
over here te a does not want to bring
his rook from f8 to e8 just because he
does have this strong attack now that
the Knights no longer pin as soon as he
moves this Knight anywhere on board he's
now opening up with a very dangerous
attack on f2 so getting his other rook
involved makes a lot of sense now the
Queen's gonna come to d2 also one of
those spots where you want to get your
queen involved into the game but I think
he probably should have developed his
queen a little bit earlier but this does
protect his bishop here on g5 which he
does need to do Bishop here to Abby for
pinning down this Knight right here this
night is really kind of the only thing
that's putting pressure on these pawns
on the stern of the board usually don't
have to worry about the Queen too much a
bishop taking on f6 that's completely
okay rook taking here on f6 all of a
sudden Frank Marshall can go ahead and
double his rooks here on the F I'll put
even more pressure on his opponent now
we're cover here to d1 trying to control
the center of the board right here Queen
to e5 putting more pressure on c3 and
then Queen - e - and it looks somewhat
odd all of a sudden you have just more
buildup on the night here on c3 but
Stefan's kind of going for an
interesting approach after the bishop
takes here and the pawn recaptures Queen
recaptures here on c3 he's going with
the rook here to d5 recognizing that
he's behind his opponent controlling the
center of the board he's kind of just
hanging back here he's gone for broke
hooking hoping his opponents going to
make a mistake with pawn to capture on
d5 all of a sudden the Queen comes up
here captures Ani 8 and then rook here
to f8 and then Bishop here and that's
going to be checkmate after the King to
h8 and then capture right here Frank
Marshall does not fall for that attack
but it does give him that that pawn back
so it's
not the worst thing that he lost that
pawn extra right here on c3 but now the
Knights gonna come into d4 and put a lot
of pressure on this Queen really
starting to break up the material on
board now the Queen's gonna come up here
to h5 somewhat of a mistake it's just
not doing too much on board a queen here
to e4 still makes sense it still has the
threat of if the pawn takes you can come
up here recapture on a e8 that's fine
also is still just protecting this rook
in general so that makes more sense to
me Queen to h5 seems like another just
last-ditch effort to go ahead and play
Queen taking here on e 8 but that's not
what Frank Marshalls trying to do so he
plays rook over here to f8 now Rick over
here to e5 from here rook over here to
h6 threatening this Queen now the Queen
comes to g5 and now we kind of have a
glorious ending here you can see as
Frank Marshall is just putting all of
his material just over here on the Kings
side putting so much pressure on board
and it eventually it's just too much for
Levin Scotty to deal with
he plays rook here to h3 can't really
take with his pawn all of a sudden the
knight to f3 just be brutal King would
have to move and then the Queen falls
that's just gonna be good game right
away and said decides ok I'm not going
to take with the rook so it just gave up
material so that's never good but
decides to play rook here to c5 it is
protected by the Queen the queen is now
kind of forced to move and from here we
have one of the coolest moves of chess
if you haven't seen this game I actually
recommend pausing it and see if you can
come up with the deflection of the
century up into this point so this
material case we see Frank Marshall play
Queen to g3 and from here white is
forced to resign there's just no really
good way for white to continue if we
were to see the pawn take here on g3
then all of a sudden we see Knight to e2
Kings forced to come down here all of a
sudden this is going to be checkmate
right here so that's one option if we
see instead this other pawn take here on
g3 that
so it's not gonna be good we just see a
quick checkmate right here there's just
nothing that can happen so from white if
we see maybe rook to e1 maybe give a
little bit of breathing room
all of a sudden Queens to h2 the King
moves and then we see checkmates it's
just all bad from there another option
that we could see probably the best
option from white is just go and take
with the Queen so Queen takes right here
Knight to e2 the King's gonna move the
Knights going to take here on g3 can't
really just take right here because the
rooks gonna come down checkmate so
that's bad instead we could just see the
King come back here and then we just
could see it continues so Knight back
here to e - if we wanted to kids just go
ahead and capture on f1 if we wanted to
after the pawn takes here on h3 then all
of a sudden Knight to d2 just way too
much material on board an extra minor
piece white would kind of be forced to
resign against stretch a strong chess
master but I thought it was fitting it's
always nice when an opponent understands
when the game is lost and they resigned
at a really nice spot and so on board
after Queens to g3 knowing that it's
lost he decides to go ahead and resign
at this point in the game this is where
these spectators apparently started
throwing gold coins on the game I hope
that it was just because they were
overwhelmed with excitement they hadn't
really seen anything like this really
great move by Frank marshals so
congratulations to him for all the chess
fans out there if you hadn't seen this
definitely one - so watch just because
so fun so hopefully you guys enjoy this
video a really cool to see players back
in 1912 playing such fun and exciting
chess I don't think we always see that
as much nowadays less mistakes less
going for broke in this sort of sort of
game but always good to see it 1912
Frank Marshall Congrats so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video and I'll see you
guys in the next one thanks for watching